parmi les pires moments de votre
carrière évidemment il y a cette
polémique sur les vaccins contre la
grippe h1n1 donc vous y revenez vous
répondez point par point aux critiques
et vous concluez que si c'était à
refaire oui vous le referiez à l'heure
des regrets vous en avez sur quoi au des
regrets j'en ai surtout les combats que
je sais pas pu mener à bien des combats
qui nous tenait à coeur
il ya tellement de choses que j'ai que
j'ai pas pu faire sur les 3 et la
culture d'ailleurs ça ça nous faisait
rire avec frédéric mitterrand parce que
c'était vraiment oui un rêve d'être
ministre de là culture et quand j'allais
lui rendre visite
toc toc dans son bureau de la rue de
valois
il me disait toujours j'ai l'impression
de voir le croque-mort de lucky luke
tu viens prendre des mesures et je
disais tu n'abîme pas mais mam l'a dit
cette option est ce qu'un jour je serai
ministre de la culture et je serai
jamais ministre de la culture mais je
suis en quelque sorte un petit ministre
de la culture en investissant dans tes
dents des manifestations dans des
associations culturelles vous êtes une
fan inconditionnelle d'opéra d'ailleurs
fan inconditionnel